[موسيقى]
يحيكم مشاهدينا من جديد مذكره التفاهم في
مجال المواد الهيدروكربونيه التي وقعتها
حكومه الدبيبه مع تركيا بشان التنقيب عن
الطاقه في البحر المتوسط يبدو انها تتبخر
حيث قضت محكمه استئناف في طرابلس بوقفي
تنفيذ مذكره تفهم الليبيه التركيه حول
النفط والغاز بناء على دعوى تقدم بها
محامون اعتبروا ان حكومه الدبيبه يمنع
عليها عقد اي اتفاقيه الدوليه وذلك بناء
على دعوه تقدم بها محامون اعتبروا ان هذه
الحكومه لا يحق لها التعاقد وطرح اتفاقيات
كهذه ووفقا لمعارض زي الاتفاق فانه يعد
اتفاقا نفطيا كاملا وعلى نطاق واسع ولا
يخدم مصالح الشعب الليبيه العليا كما انها
لا تساهم في حل الازمه العالميه للطاقه
والغاز كما انا الاتفاقيه مخالفه لعده
بنود من قانون النفط ابرزها عدم وخبرات
الشركات التركيه في هذا مساءل وايضا هناك
مخالفه واضحه لقانون زيوان المحاسبه
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
رمز الرميح مستشار منظمه الليبيه لدراسه
الامن القومي اهلا بيك من اسطنبول طه عوده
اوغلو المحلل السياسي اهلا بكم الى هذا
النقاش واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من اسطنبول
يقول البعض سيد طه بان اسطنبول
المتضرر الاكبر بعد وقف العمل بهذه
المذاكره همم وقف العمل بهذه الاتفاقيه قد
يسعد اطراف قد يصعد البرلمان الليبي شخصيه
سياسيه
صالح او بشاغه جهه دوليه كاليونان ومصر
ولكن لم يسعد تركيا باي شكل من الاشكال
كيف همم
تتلقى تركيا مثل هذا خطوه
تحياتي لك في البدايه واستدل المشاهدين
يعني بدون شك يعني كما تعلمين ان هذه
المذكره التي وقعت اوبريمات في اكتوبر
الماضي هي احدثت جدل كبير تتذكريه في تلك
الفتره وخاصه بعد الزياره التي قام بها
وفد كبير على راسهم وزير الخارجيه انا ذاك
شاويش اوغلو وكانت هناك ضجه كبيره وسبب
الضجه كانت في تلك الفتره ليس لوجود تركيا
وتوقيع على هذه المذكره ولكن هو فقط
بانها هي حكومه غير شرعيه وحتى تتذكرين
تصريحات التركيه
لانه يقول معارضوه هذه المذكره بان ليست
هناك شركات تركيه همم لديها من ال همم
تجارب او لديها همم ما يمكنها من التعامل
مع الجهه الليبيه للاستخراج او للتنقيب عن
والغاز هذا ما يقول على الاقل المحامون
الذين تقدموا بهذه الدعوه
لسيده الكريمه هي ان هناك نعم هناك بعض
المحامين وبعض الجهات الرافده لهذه يعني
الاتفاقيه او بين قوسين المذكره يعني هي
كانت ممكن التوقيع عليها وكان هناك اتفاق
يعني ممكن بعد اشهر يتم همم الغاء هذه
الاتفاقيه هذا النقطه نقطه اخرى هناك صراع
كبير على السلطه ما بين حكامتين حكومه
حكومه باش همم كل هذه يجب ان تنظر بعين
الاعتبار هناك ايضا نقطه اهم من وجهه نظري
وهي متعلقه بالتوازنات الدوليه وخاصه
نتحدث عنه الان الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وظهوره او بروز موضوع الطاقه الى الواجهه
من جديد كل هذه هي تتمركز او في منطقه
واحده وتضع يعني هذا الملف همم في همم
موقف حساس او وضع حساس في الغايه ايضا
اخرى
ساعود لك في هذه النقطه الاخرى ولكن
همم عن اختلاف همم القراءات فيما يخص هذه
المذاكره اسال ضيفي همم الاستاذه رمزي
استاذ رمزي هل تتفق مع الاستاذ طه بانه
هناك حسابات داخليه ليبيه هي التي اودت او
دفعت بفشل هذه المذكرات وهذه الاتفاقيه او
هناك توافق ليبيا على ان تركيا لن تفيد في
شيء فيما خصوص موضوع تنقيب بان هذه
المذكره قد تدخل ليبيا في همم علاقات
متوتره مع مصر مثلا مع اليونان مع قبرص مع
جهه دوليه همم عديده لم تقبل او عرضت هذه
المذاكره
اهلا بك اختي الكريمه العزيزه استاذه ريم
واهلا بكل مشاهدي ومتابعي العربيه ولا
العربيه الحدث وبرنامج بانوراما في هذا
المساء
اختي الكريمه اييه سالتيني عن رايي في ما
قاله الضيف وانا لن اسمح له بتظليل
المشاهد والمستمع الذي يستمع الينا عبر
اكبر قناه وافضل قناه القناه رقم واحد في
العالم قناه العربيه الموقره وسوف ارد برد
قانوني ورد منطقي ورد امني ورد وطني ليبي
اا يجب ان نكون منصفين ونتحدث بالامانه
العلميه والامانه الاعلاميه عبر بانوراما
العربيه ان اول من فتح المجال للخيانه
والعماله والتامر وانتهاك السياده الليبيه
وانتهاك الكرامه الليبيه هو فايز السراج
ومعه باشا في اكتوبر 2019 عندما وقعوا
اتفاقيه تصل الى تهمه الخيانه العظمى مع
الدوله التركيه لم يكن مخونا الثرات فقط
استاذ رمزي حتى نشري مشاهدينا تحدث عن
اتفاقيه اخرى وهي اتفاقيه امنيه كانت
ابرمت في 2019 واليوم نحن في حضور اتفاقيه
اخرى تفضل اكمل
استاذ ريم انا اعي ما اقول
واذكر تحديدا الاتفاقيه الترسيم الحدود
البحريه التي وقعها السراج وبشاغه في
اكتوبر 2019 وبالتالي مذكره التفاهم التي
اوقفتها همم اليوم الشقه المستعجل بمحكمه
الاستئناف طرابلس هذه الاتفاقيه او هذه
مذكره هي في الاساس كانت الاتفاق يتوقعها
السراج وبالتالي الكريمه همم الضيف يتحدث
ويريد ان يشتت انتباه وليست المشاهد بان
هناك توازنات اقليميه دوليه نحن الان عبر
بانوراما العربيه نتحدث عن امر سيادي وهو
القضاء الليبي المستقل الذي وكل التحيه
وكل التقدير وكل التوقير لرجال ليبيا من
الامن القومي والنيابه العامه والمحامين
والقضاء الذين اوقفوا هذه
المذكره واعطوا الدرس ونجلاء المنقوش
وغيره خونه العملاء الذين يريدون انتهاك
السياده الليبيه وبالتالي ليس لنا علاقه
مطلقا بتوازنات روسيا بكين امريكا نحن
نتحدث عن دوله ليبيا هذه الدوله العريقه
هذه الدوله التي لديها رجال ان كان ان كان
اردوغان ونظامه والارهاب الاجرامي الدموي
في ليبيا وشمال سوريا وشمال العراق يد
يعني يعتقدون انهم يستطيعون مجراه رجال
ليبيا فنحن الذهب بالمرصاد ونحن
الرد على الاقل اسمح لضيفي بحق الرد استاذ
طه كما استمعت الاستاذ رمزي همم يربط بين
هذه الاتفاقيه للتنقيب عن الغاز والنفط
باتفاقيه سابقات تتذكرها حضرتك اتفاقيه
2019 الخاصه بتفاصيل امنيه هو يربط بينهما
ويقول بانه وكانه هناك همم سعي تركي لخرق
السياده الليبيه يضع هكذا الامور بهذا
الطرح
طيب سيدتي الكريمه يعني حاليا عندما يتحدث
عدم خلط الاوراق وموضوع الطاقه وموضوع
الحرب الروسيه يبدو ان ضيفي هو لا يتابع
ما يحدث في المنطقه نحن نتحدث بطريقه
علميه بطريقه تحليليه هناك اتحدث لك في
الشان اللي بخصوصا كما يريد ضيفك حاليا
هناك القلق اشرت لك قبل القريه القلق من
هذه التوقيه على المذكره هو كان ضد حكومه
البيبا وهذا الحكومه هي التي جاءت الى
انقره لتوقيع على هذه الاتفاقيه وهي تختلف
تماما على اتفاقيه التي وقعت في اكتوبر
عام 2019 خاصه المتعلقه بالموضوع البحار
موضوع يعني همم خاصه بالشرق المتوسط هناك
قلق او خوف من بعض الجهات في ليبيا ان
يستاثر طرف على اخر طرف اخر وقت صوت ان
تكون يعني حكومه الدبابه هي اكبر يعني
تاخذ لها سلطه اكبر من حكومه حتى اعتقد هي
المشكله الاساسيه بمعنى
بان الموضوع ليه بيليه
هو مصياده ليبيه تخص الجميع واتفق الجميع
على اا عدم صلاحيه هذه المذكره
ولكن هناك يجب ان نتفق على نقطه اخرى نقطه
وهي ان هناك صراع صراع كبير في ليبيا وقبل
هذه المذكره لاحظنا ان هناك زيارات العام
الماضي هناك زيارات حتى من عقيده صالح همم
الى همم تركيا وتم هناك توجيها الاتهامات
الى الذئب ولم يتم توجيه التهامات الى همم
انقره يا انقره تتحدث بان هي فقط ان هذه
اتفاقيه هي تخدم الجانب التركي والجانب
الليبي هناك مصالح فقط لما صالح هي التي
تتحدث ولكن يعني عندما تحدث
رفض على اي نقطه حتى افهم
اولا اختي الكريمه الضيف لا زال مسرا ان
التنازع السياسي في ليبيا هو وراء هذا
الحكم وانا اقول له عندما يقول لا يتابع
انا مستشار ام القومي ليبي واتابع كل ما
يحدث في ليبيا والعالم بدقه متناهيه هذا
الامر ليس له علاقه بالتنازع بين بشاغه
بيضه هذا الامر له علاقه بان اولا وهذا
الامر لا يغفل عليه القضاء الموقرون
والمحامون القادرون في ليبيا وجه الرفض
لهذه الاتفاقيه امرين جليلين واضحين
بسيطين الامر الاول ان اي اتفاقيه يا ضيف
يا محترم من تركيا اي اتفاقيه في العالم
وفي الاعراف الدوليه يجب ان توقع من
البرلمان المعتمد انا اسالك على الهواء
وامام المشاهدين لماذا تركيا
يعني اصدرت قراره في برلمانها بتوقيع
الاتفاقيه واحد اتفاقيه توقعها اردوغان مع
السراج والبيبه الى البرلمان التركي وانتم
وقعتم عليها في برلمانكم هل نحن وقعنا
عليه برلماننا لن نوقع على هذه الاتفاقيه
هذا النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه احيلك
يا ضيف من اسطنبول الى اتفاق جنيف الذي
يمنع ويحضر على حكومه دبيبه كحكومه تسيير
اعمال ان تتصرف او توقع اي اتفاقيه مهمتها
هي انجازات الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه فقط وبالمناسبه استاذه ريم
الخيانه العظمى والتامر يلحق حتى اعضاء
بعض مجلس النواب وعجله صالح الذين تواطئوا
وذهبوا وانبطوا الى اردوغان ووافقوا على
هذه الاتفاقيه ولن يرحم احد وانا اعي ما
اقول استاذ غريب الكل سوف يحاسب ان كان
حيه
مع حفظ الالقاب كانوا وافقوا على اتفاقيه
2019 ولكن فيما يخص هذا الاتفاقيه كانت
هناك انتقادات وعرضوها كذلك ولكن ان كانك
تعليقه استاذ طه فيما خصمتفضل به ضيفي من
نقاط يقول بانه همم
لم يكن هناك احترام من الجانب التركي لا
السياده الليبيه ولي تفاصيل اقرار هذه
الاتفاقيه في الداخل الذي خاصه
يعني
انا اعاده الله احب ان اتحدث في اي مثلا
برنامج ارد على على الضيوف ولكن اسمحي لي
خاصه تتحدث عن موضوع ان هناك البرلمان
التركي البرلمان التركي هنا هنا دوله
مؤسسات عندما همم تقوم هناك بتدخل تركي في
العراق او تدخل في سوريا هناك اجتمع
البرلمان ويجب ان يوافق على هذه القضيه
يعني حكومه رضوان هي لا تقرر هي هناك مجلس
وبرلمان هو الذي يقرر وهذا يسير في نفس
الموضوع في همم الشيء اللي ليبيا اشارتك
حتى انا همم يعني اتفاقيه السراج في عام
2019 يعني هي كانت هي تربيه من حكومه
السراج نتيجه الى انقره وهي التي وقعت نعم
كانت انقل هي مستفيده همم مستفيده جدا
لانه كان هناك صراع في تلك الفتره تتذكرين
في 2019 2020 صراع محتدم في منطقه شرق
المتوسط وخاصه فيما يتعلق في الغاز والنفط
ما بين تركيا واليونان
ساعه هذه الدائره بشكل كبير عن قرار ارادت
من خلال التوقيع على هذه الاتفاقيه ان
تحجز لها مقعد في شرق المتوسط لاحظنا خلال
اشهر الاخيره الماضيه هناك هدوء في تلك
الفتره وخاصه فيما يتعلق في التقارب
التركي المصري على الرغم من ان اتفاقيه
الاخيره نعم هناك رفضت او تم انتقادها من
قبل همم مصر ولكن كانت في تلك الفتره هناك
مشكله في اكتوبر حتى مشكله كبيره ما بين
توتر كبير ما بين تركيا
واليونان يعني وخاصه فيما يتعلق
اليونانيه في شرق المتوسط وايضا في منطقه
بحر
ايضا مشكله تركيا
بان هذه هي المسمى الاساسي هي مذكره تفاهم
وليس اتفاقيه تم التوقيه عليها بشكل
على العلاقات بين البلدين كما يقول
مراقبون سنكتفي بهذا القدر حتى الان نعود
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع في حلقه اخرى من
اسطنبول طه عوده اوغلو المحلل السياسي ومن
القاهره رمز الرميح مستشار منظمه الليبيه
لدراسه الامن القومي شكرا لكم